[Music]
this is john callahan
is the name big bang a misnomer from
what i recall we don't actually have any
evidence the big bang started with an
explosion like a supernova or a black
hole merger yeah so
first of all
the big bang
was a name given to this idea that the
universe started in this one primordial
explosion it was given pejoratively
to this idea by proponents of what at
the time was known as the steady state
theory hypothesis of the universe one
way the universe always was and always
will be
even though it's expanding
it's always been expanding
and
matter is spontaneously created in the
vacuum
to fill in for where
space is getting thinner
so that you'd always see a universe that
looked about the same this is called the
steady state hypothesis
you could
get that out of einstein's equations of
gravity that was allowed but another
solution was one where we're either
collapsing or where we're expanding all
three solutions were allowed
the one with the big bang itself
uh there was eq it was an equal
competitor to the steady state theory
for decades until we finally got some
evidence to support the big bang and
that was the famous micro cosmic
microwave background this is a leftover
signal signature
from an explosion that started in one
hot primeval fireball 13.8 billion years
ago thank you sir okay you don't need me
for this no
that was the only thing i remember with
the 13.85 you're showing off now no i
was just showing off okay right so so it
was it was given as a as a as a funny
pejorative name but it's stuck and and
if it fits it fits now it's not clear
how much noise it would have made
because just the expansion of space
itself is not you know that's not
associated with noise in space is vacuum
anyway and noise doesn't propagate so
if you don't want to call it the big
bang because it was probably made no
noise
[Laughter]
you think you'd fix that by now
no you call it uh the
how about the main event
let's get ready to blow up
yeah i think the the big event but you
know yeah the main event well you've
talked about laws and theories and what
used to be called remember the whole
theory that's a that's a subtle point in
the old days we come up with an
understanding of the universe a new law
has been discovered that's a very
exciting time in science when that
happens and then you learn later on that
with better instruments and more tools
and deeper thinkers that what you came
up with as a law was a smaller subset of
a larger understanding
so you don't really you shouldn't call
it a law right it's it's a but it works
right so we just use the word theory for
everything that works now right and if
you just have an idea it hasn't been
tested we call hypothesis paul's
hypothesis right well there's a lot of
those
about paul's bs hypothesis
you know but there's something he said
right exactly
um
there's something you said in this
context you said uh quotients what
happened in the 20th century is that we
came to learn that whatever we determine
to be true about the universe may only
be a subtext of a larger truth yeah
that's right not that would later shown
to be wrong right so it's not like
science goes from one truth to another
truth discarding previous truths not the
physical sciences at least um not since
the 1600s have we been in that situation
before the 1600s that's about when we
uh
the methods and tools and practices of
what we now call modern science were
forged
galileo francis bacon folks said you
know if you have an idea about how the
world works you should test it
i don't care how it looks yeah i don't
care what your senses tell you come up
with an experiment that goes a little
beyond your senses or extends your
senses
galileo had a telescope uh liu and hook
oak had a microscope you start seeing
directions that were previously
inaccessible to your sensory system
right your eyes your your sense of touch
taste smell and so the universe comes to
you now
outside of
your the experience of your senses right
and the experiment then becomes the
measure of what is true not whether it
makes sense and one of my recent books
the the the front piece the i mean the
the epigraph epigram grammar epigraph i
always forget what they're called uh if
you don't know i'm not it's i just said
i just lead i just i just
baptize people into this by saying
the universe is under no obligation to
make sense to you yeah
but it's it's but we're always in a
state of subtext then in some way
possibly yeah there's some things we
might know completely right but uh let
it be open enough to say this is a
subset of a larger understanding
newton's laws of motion and gravity
worked did he experience anything faster
than a running horse well that's for the
gravity of the earth right and so it
worked right in fact it got us to the
moon and back right but then we have
particle accelerators and we can move
close to the speed of light and we say
you know newton's laws are these weird
things your knowledge is limited by what
you can do at that time in the 20 and
the correct and
and einstein came up with his laws his
theories of of mo of motion and gravity
and we learned that it's a deeper
understanding of reality that still has
limits right his you know where
einstein's theories leave what leave us
high and dry
at the singularity of the black hole and
at the singularity of the big bang
itself
it's like dividing by zero remember
you're not supposed to do that in math
class right right okay so there's a
there's a poster that's probably a
t-shirt by now that said uh a black hole
the center for black hole that's where
god is dividing by zero right okay so i
thought that was cute so so
singularities are now the frontier of
string theorists and others who are
trying to take it to the next level
just one other thing on this
hawking said the boundary condition of
the universe is that it has no boundary
is that sort of what you're
that's a way to think about it i think
that's a it's it's a it's an
organizational thought right for you
okay you can say what is
uh here you go ready uh holding flat
earthers aside
so i assume you agree that earth is
spherical
that depends
okay
so
so if i say to you
start walking and call me when you get
to the edge of the earth
you'll say i'm not going to do that
because earth has no edge
meanwhile you can walk forever
and never get to an edge right so what
are the boundary conditions of the earth
is there an edge no
there's no edge right so so so you can
have things that have no boundaries
they're real the surface of the earth is
wonderful so if you can have that on
earth
now you go to higher dimensions you can
just go to whole other places with that
and imagine an entire universe that has
no edge right and no boundary you can
have no boundary in time we live forever
as a universe there's no boundary at the
other end of time i got to tell you i
love you your job's annoying because
there's never an answer at the end of it
no we got so no no no i take you to
places where we don't have answers
because that's where things are coolest
but there's plenty of stuff we have
answers to
the age of the earth where humans came
from i got this uh okay to quote dr
tyson he's quoting you heavy elements
are forged in the cubicles of dying
stars crucibles oh crucibles of dying
stars wait did you misread that or did
he miss writing i misread that so what
do we have you for yeah
aren't you college educated
indeed i am but i'm only here because
i'm charming okay uh in other words to
get protons to stick together they need
high heat and pressures so why wasn't
there enough pressure to create anything
heavier than hydrogen and helium in
whatever started the big bag oh
snap yeah this guy has done some
thinking here
i like it
okay so good good one so at the
beginning of the universe he knows that
the conditions were just right to not
only forge matter out of energy
this is where you get your protons that
are the nuclei of hydrogen hydrogen is
the simplest element that's the one that
was up in the corner of the periodic
table exactly the opr table begins there
yeah right there right there one proton
the first step the first step and helium
has two protons and lithium has three
protons and and it just goes on and on
and on carbon has six protons
everybody's got a unique number of
protons and that's the identity of the
element so here we start with hydrogen
we take protons slam them together and
make helium
okay so why don't we keep making other
elements in the early universe we do a
little bit of lithium is made
trace amounts and that's because the
universe at that time was a little
depressed
and so
needed a little bit he said we
some of that right so watch what happens
while the universe under high
temperatures could have been making
heavier elements it is also expanding
right becoming less dense
and as your density drops
the likelihood of
particles colliding
goes down exactly it's the difference
between living in new york city and
living in rural kansas your chances of
having an accident go way down when
you're in rural kansas well uh uh the
chances of walking into someone that's
what i mean right colliding a collision
accident a collision of any kind right
in principle but yeah so
so yes and
so while the universe is expanding
matter is not only becoming less dense
it's also cooling
and so the speeds of these particles
drop
and so in fact you can look at how much
hydrogen and
and helium is in the universe
in parts of the universe that have not
been altered severely and go back and
deduce what those conditions must have
been
at the same time you can go back and
derive these from first principles and
those two num those two calculations
match up
and so that's why we have very high
confidence in what was going on in the
early universe nice yeah and whereas in
a star you make your hydrogen you have
your helium right and you just keep
going up the chain and you are hot you
are dense this stuff doesn't get less
dense down there it gets even more dense
you're good good to go see so okay
that's great yeah i said it it gets more
it doesn't it just gets it's there
contained whereas the universe is
expanding and cooling right that's the
difference great question that is a
great good way to go james brown
brown
are there any ways we can create a
virtual singularity
where we can represent the beginning
dylan is coming to us from washington
township in new jersey so would we be
able is there enough information about
you know uh i mean of course the
background radiation is always there and
it's always happening but
the event itself the singularity itself
could we do we have enough information
to recreate a visual representation of
that singularity
to some degree i would say a little bit
after
you know when the universe starts to
expand yeah so we can't get the birth
but we could maybe get the slap on the
ass the baby slap on the ass we could
get but we couldn't get the actual you
know pretty much you get that first cry
out get the first cry but not the actual
you know it's crowning like that that
all right all right
i think wait wait
i am totally freaking carter out with my
description of the verse that the
we don't know okay
why we don't know
that we can sort of describe what what
and back to a certain point but uh so
that that very beginning
uh is is something that that we
extrapolate our physics
to the point of the the greatest
pressure and temperatures that and then
we test this and the largest you know
atom smashers in the world
you know like at cern and and so forth
to really kind of look at what those
conditions are right um but quite a bit
of mystery when you try to go all the
way all the way back that's right first
tiny fraction of a second right very
hard to get information and so we're
left with theory and theorists of course
like to argue with one another and then
and then
yeah and then looking at how the
universe expands and and uh that we can
track that to some degree okay um and
and that's uh a visualization of that by
tom obel and his uh visualizer ralph
kahler is in dark universe if you come
see that so sweet the evolution of
essentially structure over time the
universe is expanding but locally it's
contracting because of gravity and so
you end up with this giant sort of web
this cosmic web which we actually
observe and you can even in a small
telescope you can go out
i grew up in new jersey and you you
could look up and the constellation
virgo that's why it's called the virgo
cluster and you see
you see galaxies even even a small
telescope so you're looking at a a local
area of downtown which we are not and in
the same way that we're sort of in the
suburbs of the galaxy it's probably a
good thing it's a good place to raise
the kids about we're so uptight here on
earth because we're living in the suburb
of the galaxy well it's a little more
stable than the raucous ride in the
middle of it maybe someday when we grow
up we can go downtown downtown right
the center of the galaxy exactly the
really good radiation but not by
yourself and not unaccompanied young man
and i mean that
[Music]
you